what's more fun than 50 bartenders in
Vegas I'm literally competing against
the best bartenders in this country
seven start sound good luck it's
actually good time this is actually
about to happen those looks like then
that weird could have gone a little
better I was like you know a little
shaky once it was under the tent it's
all nerve I don't know what's gonna
happen though the marquee right on this
big empty space there and my wife is a
burlesque dancer and since we've been
together we've always wanted to combine
our two passions with like opening our
own venue so craft cocktails and pretty
girls definitely been looking at
buildings around town we've looked at
quite a few looks like there's two
levels which is nice you know the trick
I hit really hard economically with the
car industry and all that I think the
trick it's a really bad rap you know
we're both born and bred Detroiters so
it's like we want to keep investing in
our city definitely and to help it grow
winning the competition would definitely
really help lead us to our final goal of
opening up our own space you know I
definitely think I have a shot you know
not just let out somebody you have a
shot for the whole thing I hope I do
shiny they might do it well how are you
I'm swap with the morning
where you from Detroit it was saying
some great things about Detroit and the
cocktail scene up there you're
definitely uh definitely trying to make
a make a name for ourselves up theirs
ready to go guys
cocktails kind of a play on a Ramos Gin
Fizz but with a little bit of a cheeky
inspiration so here I have a cinnamon or
shot I was a little shaky at first but I
kind of like leveled it out I was
totally nervous but I think I think I
played it off I don't like I don't look
too bad I don't know how it looks
actually do an egg white
this is that that was the hard part
building it you know we shake this one a
little bit longer kind of like a gym
stairs once I started shaking I think I
was like there's a lot happier I'm gonna
do a little bit of grated cinnamon up
here for you guys there you are
cheers Ellen you don't like about this I
was actually concerned that the the gym
might be hidden a little bit look you
know math but it sounds off thank you I
feel like I'm kind of like hi like I
just kind of feel like I think I've had
so much like adrenaline and nerves and
everything so I'm just kind of like
happy and able to be here anyone
cocktail I'm drinking my own cocktail
I'm gonna take one with me I like I've
always been an artist Lee I went to
school to study to be an artist the
thing that drives me to make art is
connecting with people and reinforcing
that we're human beings so the
connection to cocktails is when I give
somebody something that they never knew
that they wanted and that smile
immediately appears on their face that's
the human connection if I win it makes
that ability to do what I do
anywhere possible and open more doors
for my career in
I feel you automatically get a few more
sex points for like a nice little stuff
you stir with one hand double
yeah that's pretty badass in my drink
specifically there were some botanicals
situate that shaking would their impacts
my drink is a stir drink I had been told
that a surgery would win because it's
never won so when the judges sat down
you know I was just trying to be me Sean
so the drink I'm making for you guys
it's called the Julius Henry it's just a
basic stirred cocktail with a whipped
cream float ounce and a half of Bombay
Sapphire got a half ounce of Aperol I've
got two dashes of scrappy lime bitters
stir the double stirs I didn't I didn't
know it was so rare across the nation
the reaction was amazing everybody just
exploded it kind of blew me away
I gotta your bar sure what was the
inspiration behind your drink a sense of
humor Ashley I wanted to have a cocktail
that had like a sharp wit a little bit
little growl like it's gonna give you a
mustache Julius Henry is the given name
to Groucho Marx so I just wanted to have
fun with it so this is a coriander
scented sapphire spoon to finish up that
whipped cream
I'd say I'd say without tasting it it's
definitely the most unique drinking
tonight judges don't say that to you for
him to say this is the most interesting
cocktail of the night in the most
imaginative or tender competition it was
huge I mean I can't really put it into
words it's nice to kind of relax and
it's probably like the anticipation of
going for the results I'm already in the
top there's two people left I gotta be
one of them
you